[Music]
what if i told you some of the best
indian food in la is next to this busy
highway at a gas station inside a
convenience store this guy certainly
likes it let's see how this plate of
indian burritos ended up near the dorito
aisle
at the bombay frankie company you'll
find hiram and his staff making indian
food at a gas station hi room care to
explain okay the reason why we chose
this particular gas station is because
our family is actually in the gas
station convenience store business we
had the space free for quite a while and
we thought well what a great launch pad
traditionally what you might find is
unhealthy
non-fresh fare
and when you're coming across something
that's
not only fresh but it's true to the most
raw ingredients so when we start with
that completely off the wall pairing
you're going to be starting from a
really low point so all you can go is
high and higher and we're trying to set
the bar really high
since they've opened the bombay frankie
company has received both critical and
commercial success
definitely our most popular item is the
frankie in bombay sometimes it can be a
rolled up sandwiches sometimes it can be
an enclosed sandwich what we try to do
is make it ultimately relatable to the
la market and make it really similar to
a burrito it's one of the best things
you've ever tried people say never mix
business with friends or family i say
don't knock it until you try it the key
members of the bombay frankie company is
my sister priyanka please hold
our esteemed chef mr kamal jeet singh
and our staff
[Music]
having someone come in for the first
time who's never tried indian food and
are completely engulfed by the
experience they truly realize that not
only is it an indian food coming from a
gas station and being served in the gas
station that they would try it elsewhere
so by preserving traditional ingredients
traditional preparations traditional
recipes
we're staying true to not only ourselves
but the region of food for which we
serve
and we want to make sure that you're
leaving feeling like you got the true
experience
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
getting your car washed is normally a
bit of a chore but here in northridge
people are getting more car washes than
necessary and that's because of
something delicious lurking inside
they always say what inside the car wash
how come what happened how did you get
here
it's uh really funny because nobody
would think that we are here
i'm lillian and i'm the owner of
lillian's bread and sweets and we're
located inside a car wash
[Music]
lillian opened her restaurant in the car
wash for one simple reason she knew that
being located in a car wash would
provide foot traffic and some new
clients
when you walk into cruisers you are
confronted by the smells of little tree
air fresheners steering wheel covers and
other car cleaning paraphernalia but you
are also confronted with the smell of
home-cooked filipino food
filipino food is simple but delicious
with a lot of pork chicken and beef and
rice of course we cannot eat our food
without rice
we are famous for our halo halo our halo
halo they always say is the best
in the west
it is to die for as someone who ate
three hollow hollows in 24 hours i can
attest it's really great
filipino food tends to be overlooked
internationally but it's gearing up to
be the next big thing in the culinary
world
on average in a day i will sell about
300 meals
cooking is really a passion for me yeah
because if you're not passionate with
what you're doing then you won't be able
to succeed
i'm really so grateful and thankful that
i have my team
because without them i am nothing i
think that's my secret
so the next time you treat yourself to a
car wash you can splurge on more than
just a pine scented air freshener you
can splurge on that empanada scented
plate of filipino food guaranteed to
make your car smell better than a little
air freshener ever could
[Music]
great big story we in here
mama we made it
everybody always say that i think it's
better my mom's
i think my grandma couldn't even do this
they think we we got our grandmas
cooking for us
no this is us we did that like yeah
that's a young man
trap is is take risks and prosper and
that's what we're doing in here so
that's what we use is trap kitchen 15
strips in the bag man
trap kitchen is this is a spot where you
prepare products to be distributed
underground we just use that mentality
with food we're a full-blown catering
service you also can order for delivery
during the week
my team consists of myself and three
other guys i call them my brothers my
boy a wall
um dj kev and bad news we're a small
team but we get the job done all the
time you know i mean we always crips and
bloods you know i mean doing that kind
of stuff of course i'm getting arrested
every other day for nothing they're
shooting at us so now the only thing we
worried about is some food burning up
like or running out that's it
i was talking to my mom she's like you
gotta do something son i'm like okay
well what can i do i seen the record on
blue commercial on tv i'm like damn that
look kind of cool i could probably do
something with that i know like you can
make good money cooking
i moved to vegas started culinary school
and that's where
i began to practice
my craft you know
[Music]
he really came in here from vegas he
like broke what we gonna do like we need
some money i said wait we can sell some
food through instagram i was like
posting my food and people was like oh
that looks so good that looks great and
i like okay now it's time for me to
offer this food to the streets like how
a d-boy pushes dope you know what i'm
saying
it worked
the key to our success
we never gave up man every day that's
all i think about is how can we improve
our company how can we improve our food
how can we improve the taste
even though i'm reading the house
trapping i feel like it's a real
restaurant
[Music]
all flavor no grease is a new version of
bringing unity to the community through
food
[Music]
nobody has died on this street no
gunfire within the last like five years
for a fact
[Music]
there's a ceasefire and a peace treaty
going on from the consensus of food on
108th street
[Music]
my name is keith garrett and i am the
owner of all flavor no grease and will
you look at me the whole time okay uh so
you just give that to me one more time
[Music]
all flavor no grease
actually started out in my mother's
kitchen
the way my mother made a taco was
lettuce tomatoes cheese sour cream
ketchup hot sauce so
that's the way i started
and then we transitioned into our food
truck which we are in now
the kind of food that i serve
i would have to put it under
americanized mexican food
and only reason why i say that is
because i do serve tacos burritos
quesadillas and enchiladas but i don't
make them a traditional way like nah
it's a whole different feel of flavor
baby
[Music]
[Music]
when you really think about it we're
bringing together all flavors of people
from gang members to politicians and
there's no confrontation no blood being
spilled there's no grease being spilled
anywhere but yeah we still got all
flavors here
i would love to go to the the property
areas and to just to let them know that
you can make it there is a such thing as
hope but you have to work got to get
your ass up
and do something
to see
500 plus people pull up to my truck
it really makes me think about one
person and his name is for real
cause i'm so happy
[Laughter]
[Music]
my name is cecilia chan
people said i bought chinese food to
america children's child both french
sicilian brought chinese
[Music]
this is all my sisters that's me
in 1959 i came to san francisco visiting
my sister sophie
we leave the edge of chinatown
the first time i noticed the food i said
is this a chinese food my sister said
yes i look at the menu
chops egg foo
i'm originally born near shanghai and i
say i don't remember we tasted any of
this in china so my sister said this is
american
chinese food
i decided i want to introduce my
chinese food to
usa
i opened the bathroom
on 1960 this is mandarin with the mayor
masconi the customers oh my goodness the
food tastes a total difference
a lot of dishes that we've never seen
before we had hot and sour soup the
lettuce cup the pot sticker picking up i
was the first one served in seven
seconds i didn't create that but i
introduced that to americans and now
everyone has it
[Music]
i met alice when i she came to the
mandarin and one thing another i'm a
hummer
i'm ellis waters and i'm the owner of
chai penis restaurant i've known cecilia
almost 50 years it's done it's done
cecilia's restaurant was incredibly
important
and so many people came there
and learned
and opened
chinese restaurants or tot cooking you
want the ginger juice
[Music]
so this way all the juice comes out
her food is very delicious and if it is
a little strange she'll tell you a story
about it
and you'll want to try it
every time i have a meal with cecilia i
learned something
i don't get all the credit
but i think i did something
people always said you put this in the
menu i think americans don't like it i
said
good food is good food
doesn't matter you are american and
chinese you put good food i think
everybody will like it don't you see
[Music]